[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 193 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I'm
mark merchandani and I'm here with my
colleague Michelle hey Michelle hey Mark
how are you today I'm great how are you
I'm super excited about our upcoming
interview today is a very data science
focused day wouldn't you say that's
right today we have Chris Alban with us
he's a podcast veteran he is one of the
co-founders and co-hosts of my personal
favorite podcast partially derivative
this was my favorite show from way back
when this was the original data science
podcast it is no longer running and so
I've been sort of teasing Chris like hey
you could revisit your podcast days and
join us in the studio and we finally got
him in today we're very excited he's
here to share with us many important
nuggets one of my favorite is what is
the most important predictor of success
in a data scientist and I would think
that the most important predictor of
success for data science would be able
to science all the data of course
however Chris has a different take and
it's not what you think
apparently not because science thing all
the data may not be an easy thing to
measure well super excited to get into
that but before that we also have our
question of the week what does the learn
part of machine learning actually mean
are you asking me how machines learn I
mean right they're machines right and
when I think of learning I think of you
know like studying in books and maybe
textbooks are kind of out of date now
but I'm sure that people still use them
right like there are all these different
concepts that I have from my education
background you can't take a book and
smash it against a machine until it
knows the stuff in there right
like that's not how machines work so how
do they learn it's not by osmosis this
is actually a pretty difficult thing to
describe but we'll go over it during our
question of the week before that though
we have some really really cool things
[Applause]
I know you've outlined some very fun
data science related stories here so
let's jump into it all right so I have a
couple of things that I want to share
with our audience the first one I do a
lot of talking about cute flow and one
of the most common questions I get is
but how Michelle how can you use cue
flow to set up a sea icd pipeline for
your email application but we have a
really cool article this week on our
blog and it talks about how each owl
una Banco in Brazil so they weren't the
largest banks in Brazil they give us a
ton of details about how they built a
sea icd pipeline for and now using Q
flow so if you check out the blog post
they don't just talk about why they did
it but they give you architecture
diagrams and they talk about exactly
which tools they used
so there's Jenkins in there somewhere
they're doing a lot of this in a hybrid
cloud multi-cloud setup so if you want
to see details check that out so it
sounds like a fun way for people to not
only see what they're doing but also
then to say well you know I like I can
use this to inspire my own sea icd
pipeline for whatever ml /q flow
projects I'm working on yeah that's
right I really like this example because
there's nothing really specific to being
part of a bank I believe it's one of
their virtual assistant tools that they
use to speak with their customers so all
of these principles apply to pretty much
any ml application another thing that I
really liked is also from our blog and
this is an article about why GPUs are so
high-performance so we've talked about I
think I've shared a link to some code
labs before the detail exactly why TP
use are so interesting and some of the
math behind what makes them so powerful
for very specific applications and so
this article it's an explanation of be
float16 which is kind of the secret of
the high performance that you see with
cloud TP use so it goes into some of the
math behind it and how GPUs take
advantage of that and what I like about
the article is that the B float16
approach uses mixed precision and that's
suitable for certain types of machine
learning algorithms and it's not very
well suited to other ones so this
article details the performance that
they saw using different approaches
and I also came across a paper that some
researchers from Harvard published and
they did some benchmarks so they looked
at the type of problems that work best
on CPUs versus GPUs versus TPS and they
have a ton of details on which type of
problem works best on GPUs utilizing
this be float16 approach versus regular
hardware accelerators GPUs something
you'd see maybe from Nvidia versus
regular CPU something that you can just
get on Google compute engine so it's a
good way to highlight why when you're
thinking about machine learning you know
there's certainly the aspect of building
your code and having it run and you know
of course you need to train these models
and a lot of that it tends to be
computationally expensive and so when
you use GPUs to kind of speed that up
you're also making a sacrifice because
GPUs are really good at doing some
things but not necessarily all the
things that a CPU can do and it sounds
like GPUs or tens of processing units
are very much even further down that
line of they're really really good at a
certain narrow set of things and less
good at other things so I think some
clarity on when to use which ones and
how you might focus on it and say well
well this is a great example of
something we can kind of fine-tune for a
TPU or maybe this is something we want
to stay general and keep it just two
GPUs you can kind of make those
decisions with more information about
where the pros and cons are that's right
yeah and just like in any field you want
to make sure that you're using the right
tool for the job and this is one way to
help you how do you know if you're using
the right algorithm let's take a step
back and if I know that for TP use I
should be using a certain class of
algorithms but if I want to start
writing those algorithms where do I go
to figure out what my options are I
don't know but by the way you're looking
at me I feel like you have an answer to
the question you just asked
so my last cool thing of the week is
machine learning flashcards this is
something that I came across a few years
ago and they are a set of just hundreds
of popular algorithms really sort of
classic approaches in statistics and
this is a set of cards that explains
each one of them and they're really
beautifully handwritten hand created by
our special guests today Chris Alban
what I really like about them is that
they give you very clear and concise
definition
so some of them explain the difference
between supervised and unsupervised
learning
there's also overfitting versus
underfitting linear versus logistic
regression so pretty common topics in
machine learning it gives you the
statistical background for it and just a
little refresher it's not going to
explain the whole concept for you but if
you've learned it before it's a really
good way to just refresh things so some
of the other cards that I really like
you get definitions for things like
receiver operating characteristic if
you've ever wondered what the ROC curve
is that's the acronym that's what it
stands for he tells us all about Occam's
razor Simpsons paradox explained softmax
normalization even a the r lu activation
function the rectified linear units so
if you've ever wondered about those his
flashcards can give you all the details
and I want to talk about my very
favorite flashcard if you download this
set from him make sure you check out the
random forest flashcard because it's the
most beautifully illustrated and best
explanation of my favorite type of
classification yeah I understand very
very little of this world so I'm
thinking that you know I need to brush
up on it and it sounds like the the
flashcards are a great way to do that
but they're really meant more as
supplemental material to helping learn
and I think you know we kind of talked a
little bit about how people are using
these to brush up for interviews and
there are just a great way to kind of
practice your knowledge of these
different terms different methods
different algorithms all throughout
machine learning as a whole that's right
well I think that's super exciting I'm
probably gonna go order some right after
we finish this because I definitely do
not know what random forest classifier
means or I even have a concept of it but
I'm hoping the picture is about pretty
forest the pictures will help you'll be
an expert in no time that remains to be
seen
well speaking of experts I think we are
really excited to talk to Chris so let's
dive right into it
[Music]
welcome today we have an amazing guest
that I've been trying to get here into
the studio for months if not years it's
been a while I'm glad we could finally
get this scheduled Chris it is fantastic
to have you here this is your first time
in a podcast studio ever I think this is
the first time I've been in an actual
podcast studio it's pretty cobbled
together that everything I've ever used
before but I recognize everything in
this room so I'm like I don't know is
there I feel like if you go on some
radio show they should have like all
these fancy things but this is all the
same setup it was just in my you know
closet so what you're saying is this is
all the good stuff but also it's
efficient that's where that's where you
get is the efficiency you guys opposed
to setting your own setup up like oh
okay like my wife is gone for an hour
and you start like unfurling goalies
like and create like sound things like a
crazy person no this is definitely
faster than well I'm glad that you
enjoyed the setup I think we've got a
lot to talk about but to kick things off
Chris why don't you tell us a little bit
about yourself and what you do sir I am
the director of data science for devoted
health which is a Medicare Advantage
startup so it is a health insurance
company that's what everyone asked me
everyone's like oh yeah you're like a
health to startup like you should
probably use AI to connect people to
health insurance companies like no no
this is like a regular insurance company
that we started from scratch so it's
like you know method like actual cards
from the health insurance company like a
full set up and it's a really
interesting experience from a data
science perspective because you come in
with very little knowledge of how health
insurance actually works in America and
then you you sit down and then you
actually talk to a bunch of experts who
work and devoted and you oh wow this is
complicated
this is super complicated I don't think
anyone's dealt with American insurance
and been like oh that was easy no this
is all straightforward you'll figure it
out a day or two
yeah well that was think when I when I
joined I or before I joined I did a
bunch of reading of these like general
audience books on insurance and I was
thinking I was pretty pretty smart and
then DJ Patil my boss was like imagine
how much you think you know
you know nothing and I now I realize
like oh it's crazy complicated so were
you saying that that was actually a
harder thing to learn than the data
science side oh yeah no I mean I
actually think the specialty on our team
is taking folks who are very very strong
at data science and then teaching them
about Medicare and teaching you about
health insurance because there's a whole
nother realm of information in there and
it's something that we take very
seriously because if you do the analyses
wrong like it can actually affect
people's care right in a real way these
are real this is how people get their
health insurance this is how they pay
for the doctor this is how they get you
know their prescription drugs and if you
do something wrong we have to know
immediately and we have to fix it and so
bringing people on and saying hey let's
teach you about Medicare this teach you
about Medicare Advantage that kind of
stuff is actually a lot of what we do we
have a lot of educational sessions we
have a lot of like we actually have a
channel in our slacks we use slack for
our company communication we active a
channel where people are allowed to ask
any question you can ask any any any
question that you want you can ask as
many times as you want you can ask for
clarification and the idea behind the
whole thing
is to say no like don't assume that you
know it just ask someone just ask
someone and you know that's how I work
this thing out because having cases of
startups who come into the health
insurance base that they made some
assumption and that some should ended up
hurting people's care because they
decided that you know a high number was
good and in fact a high number is bad
right and then that like affects
people's ability to go to the doctor so
it's kind of like three parted in the
approach that people need to take right
because there's this classic data
science background full of best
practices and tips and there's kind of a
general understanding of what that is
but you can't really work in this
industry without also knowing the second
part which is going to be all the
healthcare specific data the nuances the
people you're working with and then the
third part I'm guessing is gonna be a
lot of regulation around that so I mean
like they're you know if you're coming
in and you've been a data scientist for
twenty years you know a lot of this
stuff you're not fully prepared to take
this on without additional training
additional understanding
you can't just dive in yeah no I did
it's this amazing thing where obviously
Medicare is for people who are 65 and
older we basically have no one on staff
who's 65 roles see we can't dog food our
own thing like my health insurance from
the company is not my own health
insurance despite the fact we are a
health insurance company
and one of the most important things
that we do which was actually started by
DJ was that we have data sides folks
actually go to the field so for example
like I flew down to Florida actually
visited doctor's offices actually we
have our own doctors so I she went on a
patient visit and sat in one of our
members houses while one of our doctors
actually did after hospitalization and
the idea is to make it real right like
this isn't just a data point this isn't
something where you think you know what
you're talking about like go and sit
down and seed on the ground and see the
reality and then go back and work from
that point like do the analyses from
that point build the models from that
point and if in health insurance if you
don't have that I don't think you could
do the job work so what was your
motivation for joining devoted I know
you may be new to health insurance but
you're not new to health care right no
so my background is in humanitarian tech
so I worked with a number of Kenyan
nonprofits like Lucia Headey and
frontline SMS and did things like
election monitoring and global health
projects and after that I spun out a
company with a few of my friends who I
used to work with with Lucia Headey that
now works on fake new stuff called new
knowledge and then I went back after my
startup and went back and worked for a
Kenyan social good program and so my
whole background is in doing some things
that have some kind of social impact
that's the thing that I have had the
privilege of doing for a very long time
and there was just this one day where DJ
you know called me up and he was like
hey I really need you help me fix
Medicare and I was like I mean that's
know as we just talked about that's not
an easy thing to do I mean there's
plenty of issues with it currently
there's a lot of concerns there but it's
also it incredibly complex field and
that was my big thing coming in was like
I'm not trying to improve everything I'm
not trying to fix everything I'm not
trying to do that but if I could take
one step and make it a little bit better
right like if we could build something
that we would want as devoted says in
their slogan like that you'd want your
own family members to be on then you're
good right like that's it just one step
forward that's a little bit better
that's a little bit nicer that has a
little bit more you know like a health
insurance company with a bit of a soul
great we've pushed the bar forward
people's lives are better the grand
sweeping change is far beyond my
my ability to fix so you're not taking
your global healthcare perspective and
applying that to the American health
insurance yeah no this is I mean I think
the thing that I take from it is a
really really really strong humility
towards my own assumptions right when
you work at a Kenyan company or what I
was doing like flying down to Mozambique
and doing some project you have to trust
the people on the ground they know what
it's like to work in those environments
they know what it's like like how far
they can push the government before the
government retaliate it's like they know
all that stuff and so you have to come
in to someone who knows a lot about data
and can manipulate data and can work
with them but basing that on their
knowledge and that's what I've really
tried to instill with my team at devoted
is hey we have all these people who've
been working in this industry for a long
time we have a bunch of providers in the
field who know what it's like to be in
there like trust the person in the field
trust their knowledge help them and
support them but don't walk in and say
there's some logistic regression that's
gonna solve all of this let me just
figure out which what it is I think
that's like the ultimate form of
advocacy is like that true not only that
level of empathy but also that level of
just connecting with your audience and
working with them to say look you know
your area I know my area let's combine
that let's make something happen yeah
the really fun thing about data science
is you have the ability to work in a
whole bunch of areas and work with data
and you can in a bad way come to the
assumption that you could fix everything
that you understand how the data is
generated so you understand how the data
model works and thus you can figure out
every single thing and you can come up
with these grand theories and then write
a model and it fits them and then you
say hey I'm done right we're we're good
and that's not true in a lot of cases
right like your assumptions for how the
world works is not true unless you've
gone and seen it unless you've talked to
a lot of people unless you've sort of
done the legwork to figure it out and we
try to do that a lot I think one of the
greatest things of working at devoted is
the large number of people that we have
who have worked in Medicare Advantage
for a long time which means that I can
go to them be like I don't understand
how this thing happens like I'm
constantly asking like the really stupid
questions because otherwise I'm
terrified of document during your time I
devoted you came in pretty early on and
you build things up from scratch tell us
a little bit about what it was like to
come in not knowing a whole lot about
the space and asking the right questions
and making sure that you stayed on track
what was that
building up a data science team like how
did you go from zero to something yeah
so when I came in that was I think three
data scientists all under DJ and then DJ
moved to the head of technology and so
then I took over the data science team
and we had to sit down be a DJ and say
hey like what's the kind of team we want
to build right there's a variety of ways
that you could implement data science at
any kind of company from scratch do you
have the data scientists sort of sit in
the corner as a research lab do you make
a bi team that just takes tickets and
just process these tickets and then
sends out the dashboard that makes it
work those were both like valid in very
common ways we decided to go for the
fully integrated approach so every
single data scientists at devoted works
in at least one other team like actual
teams that are working on specific
things like say processing claims are
saying talking to our doctors they sit
in those meetings and they are the data
science resource in those meetings and
that means that no one has to submit a
ticket when they want to get something
done in data science they just have the
person on the shoulder who's sitting in
their meeting and say hey you know like
Jason fixes for me that is super
powerful and I think that fits our model
of making sure that the people who are
working in data science actually know
the subject matter that they're working
on that kind of stuff plus a thousand
other decisions those were decisions
that you make when you start a team like
how do you want to structure it how do
you want to build out this thing how
many people do you want what's the
seniority of people and like walking
through that slowly is my job all the
time now and did you organize things
that way so are people reporting to the
subject area teams or you solve the data
scientists under you and then everyone
just sort of belongs to another team
yeah so everyone is under me and then we
led them out to other teams and they'll
jump around a few times but the goal is
that if someone is working on something
that needs data science they don't need
to come to me and say hey can I get a
resource for this or I submitted a JIRA
ticket to make this thing work they can
actually say oh no you know they've been
sitting in our meeting for weeks and
weeks and weeks they could totally
understand what's happening they
understand you know the nuances of this
let's just have them do it and based on
your description I mean it sounds like
it's a pretty successful model like
that's something that works really well
for getting those teams not only access
to the data science resource they need
but also getting that those data science
resources more ingrained with what the
solution looks like are actually the
different pieces that they're working on
is
is this are there some challenges to
this that other people aren't picking up
this same structure or is that the same
reason why yeah no I think there is
definitely some challenges like one of
the ones that we deal with is that I
think we have nine data scientists now
under me you know we're everywhere and
devoted all over the organization and it
means a lot of times there's only a
single data scientist sitting in a
meeting so sometimes that say the
science could actually be the lone
resource for something and that means
that it can be a situation where they
don't feel like they get support and we
need to make sure that we actively
encourage that that is a real problem I
mean the other one of course is that
managing a group of people who are you
know nine people who are across like 15
different projects across the company
means that I jump around all over the
place I mean all aspects of what the
company does only for like five minutes
segments before the next part it is you
know like anything else with Casta
benefits I wouldn't do it another way at
a company like devoted but I completely
see the value if like you were more of a
product company like a straight
technology product company to actually
have everyone sitting in one room and
then you know bust out the JIRA board
and say okay cool like I'm gonna manage
what every single person does this we
March this fool we're in fact like I am
doing a lot more coordinating I'm doing
a lot more like guidance I'm doing a lot
more like hey if you need to pull the
emergency ejection handle like call me
in and I'll help you out with this kind
of stuff that is like a new structure
and I think we do it pretty well but we
are learning all the time about how we
can do it better we do retros so we do
like retrospectives of the last two
weeks every two weeks so we're
constantly like sitting cells like how
well are we doing this thing because
there isn't a lot of guide books out
that there's no standard structure for
this we're soul figuring stuff out
number one how do you scale that
approach do you see that changing like
devoted pretty hyper growth and having
nine people under you like you can still
manage that as a single person but very
quickly you'll need to have other people
so number one how do you scale and then
also like as an Icee how do I not get
overwhelmed like how do I actually get
work done instead of getting sort of
dragged into a lot of the business
details yeah I mean that's the
interesting thing about being at a
company that is hyper growth it I really
feel like that is a very like tech but I
mean it's true it devoted like when I
joined devoted there was something like
60 people and our last incoming class of
folks was 50 people so like just massive
growth those are large numbers those
large numbers there's a lot more people
who are joining every single day and as
we grow there has to be more structure
in place and the thing that I really am
fighting for a lot in trying to
structured in a way that works for that
is to allow us to cover everything but
also to allow a data scientist to sit
down and work on something for a long
period of time you know almost feels
like zone defense right you're like just
covering everything that someone comes
over and taps you on the shoulder and
says hey could you just do this for me
and you stop what you're doing and you
help them out for three hours and then
someone else to HAP's you on the
shoulder as opposed to saying hey this
is a big long difficult project that I'm
gonna work on for four months
don't bother we're trying to like split
up a team a little bit so we actually
have folks that are doing more like able
to be distracted by anything you know
anybody wants to come and ask a question
they can come and help while other folks
are sitting down and actually working on
stuff for Long wins right big longer
wins and will probably build that out
more and more as time goes on because
you do want to make sure that we are
covering the needs for everything also
there are some larger wins like things
like ml and that kind of stuff that
we're just starting to build into which
require a lot longer process before you
actually see value from it right you
have to build out this whole
infrastructure of how you train the
models and manage the models and then
apply them to our system that takes time
yes I have so many questions about that
in fact so but before we get onto the
infrastructure that you're using and
what your stack looks like I I'm curious
in hearing more about how you've grown
your team so with all of these people
that are coming in some of those are
data scientists how have you been
purposeful about who you hire who you
bring onto the team what have been your
driving factors in building out your
team yeah so when you do the fully
integrated model one of the things that
I had a hypothesis above the start which
is played out very well is that your
data scientists need to have really high
emotional intelligence they need to be
able to sit on other teams other teams
need to want them to come in and say hey
like come sit in my meeting right if you
walk in and you're a detriment to their
meeting they're not gonna invite you to
come in again right they're not gonna
want you to join join the team like sit
in with them while they are trying to
get their work done I think that's my
favorite quote of like the last year is
that your people need to have high
emotional intelligence you don't hear
people talking about that so you've
taken a purposeful approach to that how
have you done that how have you
substantiated that yeah so it's part of
our interview process so like we do a
number of things but the one that
actually works really well is that for
us anyone who interviews someone or
talks to someone or does any kind of
thing with any candidate has full veto
right to say I don't want to work this
person like this person probably
wouldn't be good for me and I'll mix it
I'll remove them right away
and that offer when people are talking
to them you know when one of my folks is
actually talking to a candidate that
offer for me to say hey if you have
anybody you don't even need to like you
know do some elaborate explanation as to
why I like if you don't feel like you
can work with that person let's just get
rid of it and find someone else it is
incredibly important because the fully
integrated model that we do doesn't work
if you're the brilliant it's not
something that works really well because
if you come in and you know someone is a
very good coder which I'm not sure
they're brilliant like actually exists
in reality but like if someone comes in
and they are very very smart but no one
wants to work with them it harms the in
team internally because people don't
want to ask those stupid questions which
is so critical when you're learning a
new field like Medicare Advantage and
other people the company don't want to
work with them that's they don't invite
them in they don't ask me to like send
someone onto their team to help them out
with the problem and so we are very very
careful with that and I don't have
obviously my team sitting in this room
with me but if you actually look to the
team you would see that people are very
kind and very honest and very open and
that's something that we've selected for
explicitly how do you give advice to
people to avoid that specific problem or
to avoid becoming that problem because I
think it's a stereotype that we all have
heard of like the rock star developer
the rock star day design whatever it is
right like this idea that someone knows
enough that they can just go off and do
their own thing and they don't know
their people to help them I think it's a
common enough that people know about it
and it can be a really difficult trap
for people to fall into what advice do
you give to people to say like hey don't
become this person I think the easiest
way that people fall in it is when the
data science team is actually isolated
from the rest of the organization right
if they're a research shop off in the
corner it is so easy to fall into that
because you're not selecting that on an
everyday basis you don't need people
with lots and lots of emotional
intelligence if there's just four
engineers sitting in the room I think in
reality you do but that's the common
perception right that you could just
find you know four great coders and put
them in the room and call it a day
that's not actually the case but when it
becomes a fully integrated model and you
people are actually working with
non-technical folks throughout the
organization and have to respect those
people's knowledge right they've been
working in the space for twenty years
you can't really be condescending to
them in any way right they know what
they're doing you're there to support
them and you can be an equal partner in
that and challenge some of their ideas
but you do have to respect
knowledge being technical is not the
advantage in the space and when you have
that it becomes very very obvious very
very quickly that not having emotional
intelligence and not being able to work
with folks in that way is a detriment
it's very very quick that you realize
that that doesn't work I get it that
there's another scenario where it's
harder to see right because some of the
engineers just don't work as well
because there's some brilliant in the
room or something like that it's harder
as the manager to only see that as the
case right because the other engineer is
basically you know closed their mouth
they don't really talk about it they
just kind of like work in a certain way
that's not optimal but they don't really
express it
when technical folks are working with
non-technical folks throughout the
organization it becomes out really
obvious and so I get it that people fall
into this trap it's totally reasonable I
think being in any kind of technology
organization there's like the technical
side right there's the code and the
servers and steam of the config files
all that stuff and then there's a social
machine there's this other part of
people's goals and desires and emotions
and all that kind of stuff and if you
don't address that you're not going to
be everywhere in the company right
you're not going to be doing the best
that you can do and that part of it if I
had some like lasting lesson from this
whole thing as I go forward is that
focusing on the social machine
explicitly like making sure that all
your folks can work with everyone is a
game changer that's completely
unappreciated yeah I totally agree with
that it's not something that people talk
about much but in my experience as well
if you can't get along if you don't have
kindness and respect in the workplace
people who would otherwise be very
brilliant just get sort of quieted and
they're afraid to ask the right
questions and that means that the
business case doesn't get addressed so
thank you for talking about that for
bringing that up
what are some ways that you can support
your team so if you have a group of
people in a room that have respect for
each other and are kind to each other
and our brilliant can address the
business problems how do you support
them at that and make sure that they
continue to be comfortable that they can
continue to grow what are some things
that you do for your team yeah so two of
them I do very clearly one I'm the first
person to ask the dumbest question like
I'm very very explicit I do not know
everything about very good vantage I
know a lot I know way more than the
average person
I work in this every single day after a
lot of time learning this stuff and I'm
still learning stuff and I'm very open
to something I don't know I'm not
pretending I know every single fact that
comes in I will ask it if I don't know
it and being the senior person in the
room who is open and
to ask that question of which some of my
team actually know the answer and they
could actually answer to me that is a
big deal like being the first person
that comes in and when we did this slack
channel that actually allowed everyone
to answer every question I was the first
people to ask the question I'm happy to
go in and say I don't know something
that your senior folks are asking those
questions is a big deal the other one is
to be very explicit about it you don't
need to be coy about the fact that you
value emotional intelligence or like
some kind of like social game just say
it explicitly like we value emotional
intelligence on this company because you
need to do your job in order to do your
job the best way possible you need to do
that you need to go and relate to people
you need to be able to work with people
people need to like you and want to work
with you
that is an explicit thing that we value
and I say it explicitly to my folks if
you don't do that I understand how that
works yeah that's amazing you're looking
at hiring a few people and I looked at
your job ad and I've never seen so many
instances of the word like love and care
in a tech job ad I was really blown away
it's clear not just having this
conversation but it's clear how the
company is run like this is a thing that
we care about that were explicit about
it I'm glad that's working for you keep
doing it and it sounds like a lot of
these things you know you may have
practiced and learned before you came to
devoted because you've quite a kind of a
storied history as it were I just never
I've never been storied I guess well I'd
love to hear a little bit more about
kind of how you became a data scientist
or how you decided that this was the
right route for you and here you had
mentioned earlier all the different
organizations you had worked with so I'm
sure there's a tremendous amount of like
cool background there yeah so I did my
PhD in political science at UC Davis and
wait a second Poli Sci is in data
science here UC Davis is a quantitative
political science program so I don't
know like honestly I have no idea who
contests like I'd the biggest icon is
like Russo is like a name that I've
heard but like everything else I did
statistics right statistics was
everything that was applied statistics
was my whole education for six years
when I was doing that PhD I got to know
some folks who were working at LinkedIn
and this includes DJ and this includes a
few other folks and they were doing such
cool applied stuff that I knew I wanted
to leave
Dameon do it they were doing so many
interesting things a lot of it with our
at the time but a lot of really
interesting stuff and when I saw that I
knew that I wanted to leave academia and
work on that kind of stuff and so when I
got out I talked to a friend of mine who
was working at the US UK Kenyan
nonprofit called frontline SMS that did
low-resource SMS messaging for like
election monitoring that kind of stuff
and I was like I wanna show up Frankie
good job and that was a you know an
incredibly humbling experience as
someone who thought of themselves as
like I have a PhD I'm amazing and then
you fly over to Morocco and then you're
like and you know the most humbling
experience of that by far was that we
would do trainings with folks and teach
them how to use our software was free
and open source and so we teach them how
to use it and we'd give him some like
physical pieces of hardware to help him
do it and doing those trainings that it
became very explicit over the years in
my mind this and a DD that which is the
next place I worked if the cops kind of
burst out in the room right like the
cops sort of swarmed in and do it you
know and really arrested everyone I was
gonna get on the plane right they were
just gonna put me on a plane and fly
back home and that was gonna be the end
of everything that's you know wouldn't
be really be a big deal but for the
other like the local folks in the room
the folks who are living in that country
and can't leave and were on the radar of
the government for the whole time I
didn't have the protection of the US
Embassy it was going to be a very very
big deal and taking their security
concerns into account we would use all
this training material and then we burn
it in a bonfire so there was like
physically nothing there that someone
else could do but having that respect
for the other person right like saying
like hey like I know a lot I know a lot
about data science I get there's lots of
hype around it AI super cool all that
kind of stuff and yet the person in the
field the person in the room they are
putting a lot on the line right to work
with you and having respect for that and
understanding that and respecting their
knowledge of these things is by far the
greatest lesson that I learned doing
that for a good number of years because
it doesn't necessarily matter what the
application is being able to respect the
user experience and and understand what
they're going through and where they're
vulnerable and you're really being
entrusted with access to parts of their
lives that could endanger them and
sounds like every data scientist should
have an experience that really helps
them connect with their users and really
the access that they have yeah and I
think it applies you know well beyond I
mean these are very serious cases like
election monitoring and health programs
but in my mind it applies everywhere if
you work at a food delivery company like
you really need to understand how people
are using it like you know you might
think that it's a 22 year old who's
using it to get beer after work but in
fact it's like you know someone on
eternity leave and they have two kids
and they're trying to you know they're
just struggling and they just really
really want it and try to understand
their perspective and their wants I
can't think of doing it another way that
would work it seems arrogant well it's
kind of clear that like especially from
that experience why you brought that
into devoted and it sounds like the big
part of the culture there ya know and
that was something that DJ and I were
very explicit about that we need to
don't assume that you understand our
members lives right so you know Medicare
Advantage in Medicare provided to every
single American over 65 so you know
people who are rich and people are poor
and so don't understand what you know
the significance of a five dollar copay
is right that might be nothing for
someone and it might be a lot for
someone and so don't build models that
assume that you know the value of that
that kind of stuff happens every single
day right making sure that we know that
and you know sometimes I think we
stumble a bit and sometimes I think we
crush it but just making sure we do it
better every single day that is what we
are selecting on the you know the
technical stuff we can train out there's
tons of people who are super technical
and super awesome
um we are trying to get people who can
come in and really make sure that they
understand the user mm-hmm so what
advice would you give to someone who's
looking for a role on a team like you're
someone who cares about their users who
places more value on the impact that
they're have rather than just the
technology that they're using yeah you
know it's an interesting thing because
we get a lot of applicants to our jobs
and a good number of them are really
trying to probably I mean it seems weird
saying this at Google but trying to
please Google with a very very very
technical analysis right like yeah we're
going straight to you know like some
kind of like computer vision but you
know adversarial Network kind of example
or something like that and that might
totally get people jobs in different
laces it doesn't get people jobs that
devoted right I'd you know that's not
something I much much much prefer to
have people coming in and
can demonstrate really good
consciousness of what the project of the
working on so say if you're analyzing
crime data in San Francisco or something
like that just like running the analysis
and then showing me a chart isn't really
you know who cares right like I can do
that everyone could do that but going
the next step and say hey know I
implemented something I did something I
went out and took this data and I gave
it to some reporter and they got an
article published or some kind of thing
to actually have some kind of you know
I'm not even saying you need to make
some massive difference for it but
everyone can run some analysis on some
kind of publicly available data set and
demonstrate some basic skill right now
like there's maybe like five or six
years ago that was yeah a great way of
getting a job now everyone's doing that
but something where I can actually say
hey know this person clearly understands
this difficult phenomenon whether social
or physical or whatever that's
incredibly valuable for me because I can
then take that person and say hey I'm
gonna put you into an environment that
you don't know anything about you don't
really know about the lives that people
who are over 65 and really poor in
Florida I will help you learn it but you
need to be an active participant in that
learning and to like sit and actually
think that this is an important thing to
learn and we'll walk our way through it
so it's about having a full story so
starting out on a project being
intentional about what you're doing and
why you're doing it and then following
through with like the technical piece is
only one part of it and it's important
but what's more important is the larger
frame for that story yeah and if you had
something like say you know to take the
crime example if you analyze crime data
like if you did some ground true things
like you went to the you know police
station and like checked to make sure
things were dude like you pulled a few
records or something like that to see if
it actually matches there's something
where you can actually say no no I'm
digging a little bit deeper into this
and everything again like I'm not saying
hey you have to do some massive social
good project for you to work it devoted
but I am saying that you know the value
of running an analysis is no longer
straight that you just did some you know
simple machine learning thing because
everyone's done that at this point every
single person that applies to voted like
has an example of that but that part
where you've gone a little bit farther
and you've kind of done some ground
truthing or you've looked into something
or like you've really tried to
understand the situation like that
stands out so quickly to me so you're
saying that fizzbuzz intent or flow is
not going to get you a job that's about
it it will not get you a job although I
did like Joel grasses fizzbuzz using
deep learning oh he has so many more
have you seen his yeah he doesn't like
notebooks he has so much more where that
came from
yeah
I do like Joel is like no way
like if someone came in using deep
learning to do a very very simple
program example like I mean it's funny
it's not what I'm looking for it's very
Joel yeah so it's more than about just
the technology it's really about
applying it and making you know making
hopefully an inciting change because of
it but also doing kind of the the active
participation in what you're trying to
do the technology around but let's talk
a little bit more about the technology
too because that part is also important
right and that is a good chunk of you
know needing to understand data science
and being able to execute on it that's
the baseline right if I don't have that
your discussion right so what is that
what does that stack look like it
devoted and what technologies do you
find to be the most interesting or
useful yeah so one of the most
interesting things at devoted that you
wouldn't realize if you saw on the
outside is that we have built our own
system for running an insurance company
so we actually have an application that
we call Orinoco that actually runs the
whole insurance company right everything
from processing claims to managing you
know member calls all that kind of stuff
and the plus side of that is that we
control that whole system right so if
one of our members calls we have very
easy access to all the information that
we have item because they're not in ten
different systems or in like one system
the downside of that is that that's a
loss of support it's a very very very
complex system it's also a very new
system because we're a young company and
so you know there isn't you know 20
years of documentation sitting under
those like you know for us on the data
science team that data comes down and
actually gets replicated down to
snowflake and then we're mostly working
on the snowflake layer that kind of
stack you know that's a very like
standard stack it works very well I
think it's difficult for folks to
actually come in and try to work in that
Orinoco app and understand the data that
comes out because I think we have
something can't like a thousand tables
or something like that that comes out of
this this piece of software and it's so
powerful if you learn that whole data
model but learning that data model is
not easy it's not obvious how everything
works you really have to sit down like
you know look at other peoples like
queries and look at other people's code
and like oh I get it that's how that
works and that's not an unusual problem
compared to everyone else right like it
was this great article
a few months ago that was like some
other large company and they tried to do
a basic like a some like you know like
that the ages of all of our members
wasn't like that and it turns out that
even that calculation was incredibly
difficult to actually do because the
data is all over the place and to get
historic data and you know the the data
models changed over time and all that
kind of stuff but yeah devoted we use
snowflake for our stack and then we you
know use periscope for analytics which
is super nice if you know sequel because
just you know grind out a lot of charts
really fast and a lot of airflow it is
thrown in there kubernetes that kind of
stuff pretty typical you know startup
stack I feel like okay and as you were
building that out did you spend more
time on the actual building of the stack
or figuring out what to build we were
lucky enough that we hired a lot of
senior folks so a lot of our folks for
example like Carla guro who's my partner
in data engineering so my you know my
parent at engineering if she built had a
lot of stuff at RunKeeper she was like
really high up run keeper and built out
their whole system so when she came in
to to run data engineering at devoted
she really knew what she was going for
and that's the same thing we did with
data science right we I've sort of seen
these things before I got my first rodeo
and these being one of the early data
science hires and so we kind of knew
what we wanted to build and we've seen
these patterns before and we can apply
them that part isn't super useful it
means that you have a lot of folks with
a lot of experience and you can ask them
how the best way to do it they've tried
all the wrong ways previously and they
can decide on the right way but it is
part of the devoted way that our folks
are very very independent and it comes
from that background that we started
with a lot of senior hires and we're now
we're moving into more like mid and
junior ours but you know for a while
there we had something like 30 or 40 you
know data science folks and engineers
and we had like two junior folks or some
small number of folks that were more
junior and now obviously like we're kind
of rebalancing it because you need to
grow but when you have so many senior
folks you can really forget to put in
guardrails for stuff because no one
needs any car traits while seemingly
nobody's city guardrails and then you
know Chris breaks something but that
kind of proach of having a very powerful
stack and a stack was very little
guardrails to something where you can
only have very senior folks in the net
you've had more junior folks you need to
sit down okay cool we actually need to
document this stuff it works for it when
you're in start-up mode it works out
pretty well but then someone comes on
and they're like oh oops I deleted
everything and you're like why didn't
you delete it everything it's not like
we didn't document it so with that pesky
hyper growth stage yeah so were there
any major decisions you made down the
road that you ended up reversing on or
anything that you discovered that kind
of said oh we need to swap something out
or that you would like to reverse
anything that you regret oh anything
that I regret I think we've done pretty
well I think we've explored some
technologies so I mean I'll give you a
example of like something I was going to
read and turn it very well we compile
our whole application so the whole
application that runs devoted runs and
go and we compile that all the time
which means that the engineers can
actually like rename table names and
recompile and those table names
percolate through the whole system the
problem with with something like
analytics - like periscope it's
hardwired like it's hard-coded the table
names and so we needed a system for the
engineers to be able to change the table
names and that to percolate in and right
as we had that problem
periscope actually changed their system
where it's all all all the charts
actually backed up on github so you
could actually just like grep replace
all the stuff and github and then plug
it back in and everything worked but
there was a moment there where I was
like wait you want to change all the
table names like multiple times a day
that's good everything was good it was
like a week later they introduced it
does it cool that was lucky I mean the
lesson for me is that you just don't
know okay like we've explored
technologies that just didn't work out
we haven't exported like so far we've
been very good or very lucky one of
those two where we haven't implemented
something and sat down said that was
terrible like what is we why didn't we
do that but I mean very young company
I'm sure that all yeah it's a scenario
that comes up now I know we're running a
little bit out of time wait wait wait I
really wanted to ask about your machine
learning flashcards okay okay
so that's one of my favorite things that
you've done I know it has helped me
personally I would even go so far as to
say that part of the reason why I have
this job at Google now is because slash
keratinized makes me blush so like like
rewind to the point where you see my
name show
in your purchase history and that was
when I was interviewing here I'm not
kidding
but I really love them and I found them
extremely useful building out my
attentive flow model whenever they ask
me about fizzbuzz so what prompted you
to do that I know you were just doing it
for yourself for a while but what made
you decide to share that with people
it's kind of a vulnerable thing to like
they're all hand drawn and they're
they're beautiful but I can see if I had
started to do that I may not have wanted
to publicize that what made you decide
to share I think that being honest and
open about stuff has always been my best
strategy and you can see you know my
personal home page has something like
600 you know little tutorials around how
I did stuff and I wrote those when I was
learning so some of them are like not
the best way to do things and people
actually go into github and I you know
sit down and say hey this is a better
way of doing it now on that kind of
stuff but I've always been totally
honest about what I know and don't know
I don't I don't feel any kind of need to
pretend that I'm not something right and
I can do that from a position of
privilege that when you're the director
of science at a hyper-growth unicorn
company you could kind of be like hey I
don't care if you think I'm not good
clearly other people do but you weren't
always that I wasn't always that yeah
it's always worked out to me just to say
I don't know and when I made those
flashcards I mean I made them because I
knew in interviews that some of the
stuff you just need to memorize like
what's a briar score just you just have
to know it like you you know and it's
it's frankly like if you walk into an
interview and you can write it on the
board with just from memory it looks
freaking impressive but my thing was
just to just to learn it some of these
things you know you have to sit down you
just memorizing what is a t-test like
what is exactly happening with
everything you could read it in a book
once the best way is just to extract
those pieces of information and just
review it over and over again and then
you know it and you have it down and you
can just pull it out whenever you need
to I use those with all of my job
interviews that's why I made them it was
a very good experience and you know I
mean over the years sure there's I think
there's been some people who've said
they've been wrong at various ways and
I've double checked them and then like
fixed them and that kind of stuff I
don't mind being wrong it's okay I think
that's good advice in general that it's
okay to be wrong and that's that's where
the learning comes from that's how we
all grow I would be so surprised if
these days that people actually sat down
and thought someone who didn't ask
questions clearly knew everything
good point you know we all know at this
point that we don't everyone doesn't
know everything particularly in data
science where people come in from so
many different perspectives I've had
some folks who knew tons about deep
learning and they were awesome and then
they didn't know basic statistics
because training come up and it was
embarrassing to them right that like is
like what's the t-test I don't know but
I can do this incredibly complicated I
call these libraries and it works and
you know or the people who come in from
Statistics and they're like oh what's a
feature that's a column that stuff it's
just always worked out to me just to be
honest and just open you know I started
out because it was useful for me to grow
and learn and at this point it's just I
guess a person can you share maybe one
of your favorite stories of someone
who's used them and shared with you like
this is how it impacted my life thank
you for providing this was your favorite
story yeah so there's if there's been a
few cases of this so I sell the cards
but if anybody can't afford them they
can just ask me and I'll give them
because it's a digital product and I've
given out thousands and thousands of
cards at this point and every so often
maybe like once every six months someone
has come back to me and said hey you
gave me the cards for free the cards
made me get a job I have now bought the
cars like that right there
that's impact right like someone who
couldn't afford it before because they
were a student and they were too poor I
gave it to them for free they ended up
studying it getting a job in machine
learning and then coming back and saying
hey like I was able to accomplish
because of you let me buy a card for
someone else like let me like move this
thing forward
that is awesome there's no other way to
say you have an impact of them that
that's a great way to scale your
personal impact I like that
okay so I think we're running a little
on time is there any last thing you'd
like to share with us maybe anything
you'd like to plug or sure we at devoted
are hiring two folks under my team
focusing on analytics you know if you
google devoted health jobs pretty sure
that job comes up and go to my Twitter
to actually learn where I actually
talked about the job and I'm really open
about what it is and what it isn't it
would be a perfect job for a few folks
and we'll add that link to the show
notes and again I've seen it there's a
lot of love and care in it's a great
description and some great flash cards
to help you prepare yeah right
yeah we'll have that link in the show
notes as well but I can't imagine
anything better to prepare for an
interview with Chris than
his own yeah someone ever like bring in
like a printed out version to the flash
cards to your own and ask you to
autograph it I have I've seen printed
I've never seen a printed one in person
but a lot of people do print them out
and then send me photos of them this one
Institute actually pasted them on the
wall like wallpaper that's really pretty
cool yeah it was pretty sweet why didn't
I print them out to get your autograph
I'll run upstairs all right Chris thank
you so much for joining us today is
great to have you here it's great to be
on thank you so much to Chris for coming
in I mean it was a supercool chance for
us to chat with him you know he's got
some very interesting things that I
would never have thought about when
talking especially about hiring and
managing data science right because you
know I think of data science I think of
a very technical very heavy skillset in
terms of needing to have a lot of
background there but there's so much
more empathy and understanding and how
to like kind of work within a team and
really understand why you are doing data
science that it seems like he takes it
as a big factor to being successful
that's right and in many ways it's
fairly straightforward to evaluate piece
of code or something that's very
tangible and very well-defined but
emotional intelligence is something
that's a lot harder to define especially
in the limited amount of time you have
for interviews to hear how he tries to
figure that out in advance before
bringing someone onto the team I think
that in and of itself is a skill because
it's such a difficult predictor to tease
out so go tweet Chris if you want a
reunion of partially derivative because
it sounds like that'll be I don't know
if there's some serious expressman there
he sounds like he could be convinced
into doing some more that's right I've
already seen a lot of people asking for
reunions
so not just Chris but Vidya and Jonathan
as well it sounds like there's a lot of
demand for that so yeah go express that
and maybe we'll all get to come together
and have a really cool reunion podcast
yeah that would be great absolutely so
it was a great conversation with Chris
but I do have kind of a follow up
question here which we'll just call our
question of the week
so what does it mean to learn in machine
learning because machines can't I don't
think they can they can't study like we
do they don't cram before a test they
don't stay up till 4:00 a.m. not that I
ever did anything like that but that
learning part of it is not as easy and
people talk about all these networks and
it what does it mean what does it mean
so we're going back to the basics right
this may seem very obvious especially if
you've been in the field for a while but
expressing it in words is surprisingly
difficult this is a definition that I
got from Chris this is one of his
flashcards this is something that I came
across what's the picture on the
flashcard the picture there is no
picture on this one but the words are
decorated very nicely he includes a
quote from Tom Mitchell who set this
back in 1997 I'm gonna paraphrase it if
you want the full definition you can
look at the card but this is a great
definition for what the learn means in
machine learning
to paraphrase Tom Mitchell a computer
program is said to learn if it's
performance at specific tasks improves
with experience oh that's not all that
different from the way we learn we read
books we gain experience we do tasks and
we improve at them and with computers
machine learning you're defining a very
narrow set of tasks you're defining that
in a way that gives you a performance
indicator so you have a task a concrete
outcome and then you give that computer
access to experience so you give it
examples of that task with success
predictors and failure predictors and it
can take that information ingest it do
something with it and then get better at
those tasks so if it has a way to more
or less mean like you said with
experience and kind of improve or change
its algorithm to figure out what it's
doing differently that would be
considered machine learning but if
someone were to come in and modify the
program manually that's not considered a
machine learning that's correct
so without changing the fundamental
algorithm so you can change parameters
and hyper parameters by the way if you
want to know the difference between
parameters and hyper parameters Chris
has a flash card for that of course
but as long as you're just changing
parameters and not the fundamental
algorithm for the program so the program
has the ability to change those
parameters and it does that based on
getting access to more experience so
through experience if it can update
itself in order to get better at these
tasks so that it's performance
indicators get better and better better
that's machine learning I have to buy
these flash cards because if all that is
on one card and there's a lot of cards
there's no shortage of them right there
are hundreds of cards yeah I mean this
is stuff that I really just don't have a
good background in so it's super cool to
hear that and I think I like that
definition right it's very simple right
like if it can learn from its experience
to make changes and usually in a
positive way hopefully it's the learning
part of machine learning it's
straightforward so if you want to find
out more including the definition of a
partial derivative by a pack of quizzes
flashcards because who knows they might
even help you land your next job
absolutely
so definitely some very cool resources
in there we'll make sure we have links
to the flash cards in the show notes I
think we're almost at a time here
Michelle before we go anything cool
coming up any traveling any new cards
you're gonna pitch the Kris did the
flash card deck yes all be in San
Francisco for the near future I'm
working on an event I'm curating the m/l
for developers track for Q con that's in
San Francisco on November 13th but other
than that I'll be right here in town
sounds very exciting so what's Q con all
about q con is I believe it's info Q
that puts this on and I've spoken at a
few of them but this is the first time
I'm curating a track and they're deep
dives
they're almost hour long talks they're a
bit different from other conferences but
I have very much enjoyed them in the
past and I'm very much looking forward
to being part of this event it's the
first time that I've been part of it as
an organizer so if you're around San
Francisco on November 13th it sounds
like your plans I've already been in for
you we'll make sure to have a link to
that in the show notes I'll be hanging
around San Francisco I'm super excited
because I just launched the beyond your
bill series which you know we've been
talking to a lot of people about helping
them understand how their GCP billing
and cost management tool like there's a
bunch of tools in there but like what
are they how do they
work how do I know what I'm actually
spending my money on all these really
really important things so I'm super
excited to launch that and we're working
on a bunch of other content surrounding
that to help people again get that
understanding of how do I measure my
costs what tools are available to me and
then really how do I actually use those
tools because in addition to using the
right tool for the job you also need to
understand how much each of those tools
costs absolutely right I mean it's like
it's such a bare metal kind of thing
maybe bare metal wasn't the right word
it's such a basic concept that you need
to understand right like look I have all
these tools available to me but if I'm
gonna use all of them I'm also going to
pay for them it's something to be aware
of when you're working on all these
things is like yes the power of Google
and the power of all these computers
around the globe are at your fingertips
but they all have different costs
associated with them too and with great
power comes great responsibility and on
that note I think we'll call it thanks
to everyone for tuning in to our data
science episode and we'll see you all
next week see you next week
[Music]
it turns out with machine learning you
can still write infinite for loops and
we don't have to worry about Skynet
because some programmers just make
mistakes you know with every piece of
software we can just write infinite
forth
[Applause]